when advanced humans or aliens or ai
systems let's say 5 to 10 centuries from
now look back at earth
on this early 21st century
how much do you think they would say we
understood about
money and economics or even about
engineering science life death meaning
intelligence consciousness all the big
interesting questions
i think they would
[Music]
probably give us a
b minus on engineering on all the
engineering things the the hard sciences
a passing grade
like we're we're doing okay we're
working our way through rockets and jets
and electric cars and uh
electricity transport systems and
nuclear power and space flight
and the like
and you know if you if you look at the
walls
that uh grace the great court at mit
it's full of all the great thinkers and
and they're all pretty admirable you
know
if you could be with newton or gauss or
madame curie or
einstein
you know you would respect them
i would say they'd give us like a
a d minus on economics
like
you know an f plus or a d minus you you
have an optimistic vision first of all
optimistic vision of engineering
because everybody you've listed
not everybody most people you've listed
it's just over the past couple of
centuries and maybe it stretches a
little farther back but mostly
all the cool stuff we've done in
engineering is the past couple centuries
i mean archimedes
you know had his virtues
you know i studied the history of
science at mit and i also studied
aerospace engineering and and so i
clearly have a bias in favor of science
and if i look at the past 10 000 years
and i consider
all of the philosophy and the politics
and their impact on the human condition
i think it's a wash for every politician
that came up with a good idea another
politician came up with a bad idea yeah
right and it's not clear to me that you
know most of the political and
philosophical you know
contributions to the to the human race
and the human conditions have advanced
so much i mean we're still taking
you know taking guidance and admiring
aristotle and plato and seneca and the
like
and on the other hand
you know if you think about uh what has
made the human condition better
fire
water
harnessing of wind energy like try to
row across an ocean
right not easy and for people who are
just listening or watching there's a
beautiful sexy ship from
16th 17th century this is a 19th century
handmade model of a 17th century
sailing ship which is of the type that
the dutch east india's company used to
sail the world and trade so that was
made you know the original was made
sometime in the 1600s and then this
model is made in the 19th century by
individuals both the model and the ship
itself is engineering at its best and
just imagine just like raucous flying
out to space how much hope this filled
people with exploring the unknown going
into the mystery
both the the entrepreneurs and the
business people and the engineers and
just humans
what's out there what's out there to be
discovered yeah the metaphor of human
beings leaving shore sailing across the
horizon risking their lives in pursuit
of a better life is a incredibly
powerful one
in
1900
i suppose the average life expectancy is
50.
during the revolutionary war you know
while our founding fathers were fighting
to establish you know life liberty
pursuit of happiness the constitution
average life expectancy of like 32.
some between 32 and 36.
so all the sound in the fury doesn't
make you live past 32 but what does
right antibiotics
conquest of infectious diseases if we
understand the science of
of infectious disease they're you know
sterilizing
a knife
and harnessing antibiotics gets you from
50 to 70 and that happened fast right
that happens from 1900 to 1950 or
something like that
and i i think if you look
look at the human condition
you ever get on one of those uh rowing
machines where they actually keep track
of your watts output when you're on the
yeah yeah it's like 200 is a lot
okay 200
is a lot so a kilowatt hour
is like all the energy that a human a
trained athlete can deliver in
a day
and probably not one percent of the
people in the in the world could deliver
a kilowatt hour in a day and the
commercial value of a kilowatt hour the
retail value is 11 cents today
and uh the wholesale value is two cents
and
so you have to look at the contribution
of politicians and philosophers and
economists to the human condition
and it's it's like at best awash one way
or the other and then if you look at the
contribution of john d rockefeller
when he delivered you a barrel of oil
yeah and then you know the energy and
and oil liquid energy or the
contribution of tesla
you know as we deliver electricity
you know
and what's the impact of the human
condition if i have
electric power
if i have chemical power if i have wind
energy
if i if i can actually set up a
reservoir create a dam spin a
turbine and generate energy from a
hydraulic source
that's extraordinary right and and so
our ability to cross the ocean
our ability to grow food our ability to
live
it's it's technology that gets the human
race from
you know
a brutal life where life expectancy is
30
to a world where life expectancy is 80.
you gave a d minus the economist so are
they two like the politicians awash
in terms of there's good ideas and bad
ideas and and that tiny delta between
good and
bad is how you squeak past the f plus
onto the d minus territory
i think most economic ideas are bad
ideas like most
you know like um
take us back to mit and you want to
solve
a fluid dynamics problem like like
design the shape of the whole of that
ship
or you want to design a an airfoil a
wing or if you want to design
an engine or a
a nozzle and a rocket ship you wouldn't
do it with simple arithmetic
you wouldn't do it with a scalar there's
not a single number right it's vector
it's vector math you know computational
fluid dynamics is n-dimensional
higher level math you know complicated
stuff
so when's when an economist says the
inflation rate is two percent that's a
scalar and when an economist says
it's not a problem to print more money
because the velocity of the money is
very low
monetary velocity is low that's another
scalar
okay so
the truth of the matter is
inflation is not a scalar inflation is
an in-dimensional
vector money velocity is not a scalar
develop saying what's the velocity of
money
oh oh it's slow or it's fast
it ignores the question of what medium
is the money moving through
and the same way that you know
what's the speed of sound
okay well what is sound right
sound you know sound is uh is a
compression wave it's
energy moving through a medium but the
speed is different
so for example the speed of sound
through air is different than the speed
of sound through water
and and a sound moves faster through
water it moves faster through a solid
and it moves faster to a stiffer solid
so there isn't one
you